c'était une idole aussi pour vous ouais
c'est une légende de johnny un gros
respect pour la carrière c'est dingue
quoi quand on est un jeune chanteur
comme ça je disais qu'il y avait des
jeunes chanteurs qui dit tout
on veut faire un concert à la johnny
maintenant parce que c'était le patron
sur scène vous en fais moi je sais notre
père lui et chanteur ouais ils
n'arrêtaient pas de nous parler d'eux
mais ils n'arrêtent pas toujours
aujourd'hui nous parler de johnny tout
le temps et nous disait à johnny lui
sert vrai et tout ça même il nous
chambrer ouais en nous disant johnny
fait mieux ouais moi il y avait un
souvenir que j'ai appris je suis pas
spécialiste la callas mais un conseil
était entré dans une main on a fait ça
c'est bien je me souviens j'étais petit
j'ai fait voir mais le gain il est
vraiment trop loin bref c'était à damas
qui nous et on l'a dit hier un jour la
main il resté bloqué de rester 20
minutes dans la main je continue
non c'est vrai ouais ouais c'est sûr que
c'est vrai que c'était à amir zogib